actor writer and producer sharon horgan
is known for sitcoms like catastrophe
and divorce providing the brains and
wits in the production morgan is now
starring in the new apple tv plus show
bad sisters a series she created our jb
wax caught up with the irish star to
discuss the new show and what inspires
her writing and work jamie good morning
good to see you good morning vlad great
to see you too sharon horgan one of my
favorite artists is an emmy-nominated
bafta winning sensation she has a style
of writing that is uniquely hers she
loves dark humor and there's truly no
topic she won't explore i met up with
her in brooklyn's williamsburg
neighborhood where she spent a lot of
time crafting some of her best work
i've definitely found myself in in my
writing dealing with something that i
wasn't able to figure out in my own you
know
personal life sharon horgan is a true
master of her craft and no tomato please
or onions
or lettuce or cabbage or anything but
meat
and says she navigates her life through
her writing i didn't have my bag stolen
i thought you said you'd had your bag
stolen my kebab
is your work
a certain level of therapy for you
yeah yeah i mean if i didn't have it i
would be a little bit worried
um for myself and for the people or
people around me
oregon is extremely self-critical yeah a
quick wit is undeniable what are you
doing uh i'm just picking up the
leftovers
just take the sitcom motherland about
competitive suburban moms
st mary's or catastrophe which explores
an unplanned pregnancy and unexpected
romance
i mean if you had any friends they would
be advising you not to jump into it like
this and she created many episodes of
the hit hbo series divorce in this
brooklyn restaurant can you check the
alarm downstairs it's making that
chirping sound oh sure thank you
her latest project is the dark comedy
bad sisters on apple tv
a murder mystery that follows five
sisters with an undertone of domestic
violence
she doesn't respect you yes your feet
it's pretty dark i mean apart from the
fact that it can be a bit crazy and
slapstick at the heart of it is you know
dangerously uh abusive relationship and
i had to just make sure that i could
represent that as authentically and
realistically and but at the same time i
had to be respectful of
the situation at the heart of it the
show draws parallels to her own life
horgan too is one of five siblings and
it was filmed in her homeland ireland i
imagine you as a very independent young
girl
when you were growing up oh no like
not really i was doing i'm really shy
really really shy i mean i didn't sort
of find my voice until i started doing
this i mean i always knew i was funny it
was sort of how you in a big family's
got attention was through making my my
dad laugh but no i didn't like have any
confidence and until i was older so i
would always have assumed that i was you
know the least interesting uh person to
talk to but i i also think like not
doing myself down in any way but i don't
think i really figured out who i was or
even what i was really good at and
until decades later
her confidence today is subtle and
modest she taps into it through her love
of dark comedy her work delicately turns
real life problems into relatable humor
you can't just explode what is it about
the dark side of life that pulls you in
as a brilliant writer of comedy i mean
i'm just attracted to
you know representing life as the most
realistic version i can sort of make of
it because i feel like that's how i
attract an audience you know when it
feels really representative you know
when it's not aspirational or
sugar-coated in some way like i love
watching shows like that i've been
thinking about that talk she says she
enjoys writing about extraordinary
messes and at the core of almost all of
her work is love
what does love mean to you what is love
i guess love for me is um
[Music]
doing anything you um can for someone
without without um question it's sort of
being able to be honest when you don't
when it's hard to be honest any time
i've written anything that doesn't have
that sort of at its beating heart it
kind of uh
well i sort of lose interest what do you
want to do that you haven't done i just
feel my perspective on my career has
sort of changed over the years and that
like i used to have this sort of blind
ambition for you know getting to the top
to me the top isn't something to kind of
aim for because you either have to work
really really hard to stay there or you
just like full
she is still on the rise and thinking
about her next big project
you know a lot of change has happened in
my life this this last while and getting
divorced and
you know teenage kids sort of getting to
that point where they might be leaving
home soon and
elderly parents and menopause and the
thing you have to do first is find an
engine you know to sort of tell that
story you know
so um but that's part of the part the
fun bad sisters is out today on apple tv
plus and it's a genre bender that's
worth you want to see it yeah
catastrophe too you would love it yeah i
like it
amazing the premise alone is great right
but i'm a big fan of divorce i didn't
know that she wrote divorce yes she
wanted to create a language if you i
hope people will google her yeah because
it's amazing to see what she's been
behind what she's been involved in yeah
i like how she says she writes about
extraordinary messes
that is
we've all had a couple of those
thank you thank you we'll be right back
you're watching cbs morning